[Musique]
donc atteint
à une heure de route de vienne la
centrale nucléaire de 100 tonnes d'or
fait unique au monde bien que totalement
achevée elle n'a jamais été mise en
service est où ici en contrebas se
trouve le réacteur on peut voir
l'intérieur mais en temps normal la cub
serait recouverte d'un couvercle qui
fermerait le réacteur
en 1978 tout était prêt pour son
lancement mais les autrichiens ont dit
non à l'atome par référendum la centrale
a donc gardé portes closes et offre
désormais aux visiteurs un voyage dans
le temps
ici nous sommes dans l'ancienne salle de
contrôle de la centrale tout est encore
dans son état d'origine et on est
transporté dans les années 70 est
privé de sa fonction première la
centrale a dû se réinventer au fil des
eaux
ici pendant trois décennies tous les
projets entrepris ont échoué
centrale au gaz qui n'était pas viable
économiquement ou encore un musée des
mauvaises technologies dans les
propriétaires ne voulaient pas
économiste paul wright et estime
aujourd'hui elle est utilisée comme
centre d'entraînement démantèlement on
peut s'exercer à démonter sans danger
des centrales nucléaires après leur
fermeture car il n'y a aucune radiation
de frais la centrale devait fournir de
l'électricité à 1 million 700 mille
foyers mais aussi développer l'activité
économique de la région le résultat du
référendum a donc été un choc pour les
habitants mais quarante ans plus tard
herman cain treiber maire de 100 tonnes
d'orge pendant 27 ans n'a aucun regret
ici il y avait environ 200 employés
évidemment ils ont perdu leur travail
mais une grande partie d'entre eux est
allé dans d'autres centrales en autriche
marthe aujourd'hui après la catastrophe
de tchernobyl puis celle de fukushima
vous aurez du mal à trouver as vingtaine
d'offres une personne qui regrette que
la centrale n'est pas été mise en route
grâce à des panneaux solaires la
centrale produit de l'électricité pour
200 foyers un geste symbolique pour
souligner l'attachement du pays aux
énergies renouvelables en autriche +2
75% de l'électricité vient de ces
énergies vertes et au premier rang
l'hydraulique une dizaine de centrales
hydroélectriques sont ainsi répartis le
long du danube comme celle de frey de
now à l'est de vienne cette centrale
fournit près de trois cent mille foyers
en électricité
l'hydraulique une alternative efficace
selon cet exploitant
l'énergie hydraulique peut produire de
l'électricité tout au long de l'année il
y à certaines variations mais elles sont
très prévisible l'énergie nucléaire
aussi est une énergie facile à prévoir
mais l'hydraulique al'avantage d'être
renouvelables locales et surtout
indépendante de tout un port de
combustible
l'autriche vise désormais 100%
d'électricité issue du renouvelables en
2030 forte de son modèle vienne a pris
la tête du combat anti atome en europe
elle menace de porter plainte contre
l'inclusion du nucléaire par la
commission européenne dans la liste des
énergies considérées comme durables ce
texte connu sous le nom de taxonomie est
soutenue par la france la guerre en
ukraine a conforté l'autriche dans ses
positions et ce même si elle importe
environ 80% de son gaz de russie
l'énergie nucléaire ne peut pas
contribuer à la protection de
l'environnement elle est trop chère elle
est trop lente et c'est une technologie
qui présente des risques importants nous
voyons aujourd'hui combien notre
dépendance au gaz russe 8 à l'europe et
à l'autriche nous est en danger et
menace notre liberté
c'est pourquoi il faut réduire cette
dépendance en sortir mais nous n'y
arriverons qu'avec des énergies que l'on
produit en europe ce sont les énergies
renouvelables cette nouvelle taxonomie
entre en vigueur alors l'autriche
portera plainte
une démarche soutenue par les
associations écologistes qui demande
toutefois au gouvernement de faire plus
pour accélérer la transition écologique
du pays
l'autriche n'a ni énergie nucléaire ni
charbon et montrent clairement que cela
fonctionne mais elle ne doit pas se
reposer sur ses lauriers pour protéger
l'environnement et préserver la nature
il nous faut faire des économies
d'énergie il faut simplement arrêter de
chauffer l'extérieur en isolant les
maisons en rénovant de manière
intelligente et en utilisant des
appareils performants
et puis les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre ont massivement augmenté dans le
domaine des transports depuis 1990 il
est urgent de changer de cap
des réformes d'autant plus nécessaire
aux yeux des associations que le pays
s'est engagé à atteindre la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2040